bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors on l'a entendu climat
anxiogène jugé par certains
professionnels de la santé quand
d'autres estiment qu'on en fait pas
assez
qu'est ce que ça révèle et où se situe
selon vous le gouvernement là dedans
s'arrêter un état de confusion qu'il ya
des raisons objectives cette épidémie
n'a pas été appréciée des départs à sa
juste valeur et sa durabilité dans le
temps n'est pas évidente et au fond tant
qu un vaccin
les opinions publiques devront
s'habituer à cette situation le
caractère anxiogène est renforcée par
l'idée qu'à partir du moment où au
confinement était terminé il y avait la
sortie de confinement la reprise de
l'activité
psychologiquement l'opinion se projetait
dans un ailleurs
et puis idées à une reprise savez ça
peut quand quand il ya une maladie grave
personnel on croise des sorties et puis
finalement elle rebondit d'une façon ou
d'une autre et donc la tendance ethnique
comme la france c'est aux politiques de
fixer la norme alors au départ il ya une
conclusion entre le un conseil
scientifique est mis en route
et puis de l'autre côté de politique
avec les autorités politiques médicales
de politique des départs semblent se
réfugier derrière le conseil
scientifique et maintenant on a le
patron du conseil scientifique
kindy la situation est grave
va falloir prendre des décisions
rigoureuses et un premier mini chant
castex qui se contente de dire
la situation s'est dégradée il va
falloir faire attention
donc tout ça évidemment nourrit une
inquiétude des français c'est-à-dire
qu'il pensait rentrer maintenant dans
des interrogations et des inquiétudes
économiques et sociales et là une belle
au fond à aa se faire une idée donc
c'est pas bon et ça renvoie la balle
toujours au président de la république
au premier
ministre en terme de communication vous
dirais qu effectivement né dans une
gestion de la crise par là par la peur
la tribune des 35 chercheurs qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure par
d'infantilisation de culpabilisation
morlaix moralisatrice de postures
protectrice à caler votre gars là dessus
non vous savez utiliser le terme de
gestion par la peur ça laisserait dire
de les autorités politiques souhaitent
au fond créé un mac bord pour détourner
l'attention du fait de cette peur ou
pour avoir des marges de manoeuvre c'est
une vision complotiste aux sombres quand
des choses sont compliquées à comprendre
on préfère moins stable on préfère
toujours se rassurer en pensant que
quelque part il ya des gens qui savent
et qui montrent des machineries dans la
réalité de son beaucoup plus aux à y
voir un contente c'est que réellement il
n'y a pas une maîtrise en ce jour que ya
un pilote dans l'avion que le blog c'est
la destination
en fait on est face à des autorités
politiques qu'il y ait entre je dirais
le risque sanitaire est le risque
économique et social et c'est de trouver
le bon équilibre ce à quoi soral dec
départ encore une fois une mauvaise
gouvernance entre ce concession ni fille
dont on ne sait pas très bien
partout les composés et puis les
autorités politiques et au sein même du
corps où la vue
nîmes il ya des désaccords et maintenant
c'est désaccord s'exprime avec le qui
disent on en fait trop et ceux qui
disent on n'en fait pas assez
est-ce que vous dirais qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est tiraillé entre d'un
côté le monde scientifique et le conseil
scientifique qui l'a conseillé depuis de
nombreux mois quant aux décisions
sanitaires à prendre
le conseil scientifique d'un côté puis
de l'autre la nécessité de relancer
l'économie ce qui fait que notamment
dans discours de jean castex
il ya quelques jours il y avait ce ton
assez alarmiste mais dans les faits pas
de réelles mesures qu est coercitive
il ya sept se dégage
libre est aujourd'hui bien sûr il ya ce
jeu de tensions le président macron vous
l'avez dit a semblé dire que le dernier
mot revenait aux politiques mais ce à
quoi il faut rajouter une cacophonie
totale à l'intérieur du corps médical
au fond les français à qui faut-il
confiance ils font d'abord confiance aux
scientifiques
bien avant les autorités politiques pour
dire le réel de la pandémie mais le
président a raison de dire que il
revient aux politiques de trouver le bon
équilibre entre risques sanitaires et
risque économique est là nous avons une
communication gouvernementale qui dit à
la fois on touche pas aux conseils
scientifiques qu'on écoute will mais le
conseil scientifique dit des choses
d'autres médecins disent d'autre chose
et donc un avis à deux problèmes ya
l'incertitude compréhensible quand l
évolution des choses le fait de tianya
le bon équilibre entre risque sanitaire
et risque économique
il ya des problèmes de gouvernance lieu
à ce conseil scientifique dont on ne
sait pas d'où part les gens puisque
clairement les avis du conseil
scientifique peuvent être publiquement
remis en cause par d'autres médecins ou
vont il faut comprendre quelque chose
c'est qu'à partir du moment où on a
développé les tests vous n'avez des
indicateurs changé de nature et donc les
choses ne sont pas très claires pour je
dirais les honnêtes hommes femmes que
nous sommes c'est à dire quels sont les
bons indicateurs
il me semble je n'y connais rien
évidemment sur le fond que le bon
indicateur c'est l'hospitalisation
parce que l'ancien directeur de
l'institut de sondage
on sait bien qu avant l'existence des
textes
la pandémie le fait d'être atteint par
locaux vides étaient cachés maintenant
c'est pas caché mais il faut en amour on
compte un petit peu même si c'était un
peu fastidieux les cours de pédagogie
que nous faisaient autrefois le l'ancien
premier ministre à pau pour bien voir
les choses donc il ya un problème de
gouvernance y un problème de pédagogie
et il ya un problème dénonciation d'une
doctrine quand l'attention aux risques
sanitaires et puis urgence économique et
social parce que ledit d'ici un mois ou
deux nous allons avoir des situations
difficiles pour beaucoup de français et
de l'inquiétude de merci beaucoup pour
votre éclairage très vague rozès
président de la société conseil analyse
et perspective enseignant à sciences po
et hec dit